author and columnist mark Stein joins us
mark
you watched last night there's so many
levels of awfulness but how would you
assess what you saw well I think the
best explanation for Bloomberg is that
he is in fact a Russian asset who has
been planted into the Democrat race to
make Joe Biden look forceful and
vigorous you said he spent four hundred
and sixty million dollars to wind up on
stage talking about non-disclosure
agreements I understand by the way that
since the debate he's asked everyone who
watched the debate to sign a
nondisclosure agreement so hopefully
none of it none of it will leak and
that's just another 460 bazillion
dollars or however many it is the fact
is you have to hand it to the Cherokee
dominatrix she's not gonna be the
candidate but she she actually uttered
that phrase you just played horseface
lesbians which i believe has not been
used in any presidential debate since I
believe Benjamin Harrison and Grover
Cleveland but to Flay him for calling
women horseface lesbians and he just
stood there looking while the horse
faced himself unable to respond to it
but then she said then she starts going
on about non-disclosure agreements he
won't disclose how many Dodd disclosure
agreements he cite and eventually it's
such a lively debate that miracle of
miracles Joe Biden wakes up and he
starts having a swig and blue god garlic
come on man God love you man
in da man I played for the NBA years ago
my son owns an Indy a franchise that
Chinese general gave him Bloomberg is
the biggest disaster of the is is the
biggest disaster of this do you know if
it is billionaire two billionaire
sensible people a great novelist Lionel
Shriver wrote at the British Spectator
the other nations
American novelist best-selling novelist
and she said people will welcome
Bloomberg as a respite from Trump no
they won't if it's billionaire to
billionaire nobody people are going to
go with the billionaire who is it like
this guy because the one thing you say
about Trump when he came up with that
Rosie O'Donnell line that he wasn't the
creature of minders he wasn't the
creature of quarters who don't dare tell
the Sultan that he's going to have to
come up with an explanation as to why so
many of the girls in the harem had to
sign non-disclosure agreements it was
pathetic probably the best summer I've
ever heard of American policy politics I
I don't think you can be presidents as
your foreign-born and and we're all all
gonna suffer because of that mark Stein
great to see you tonight thank you
thanks a lot Tucker